if a person who's fasting eats or drinks
during the
fast
unintentionally does this break his or
her fast when a person drinks or eats
unintentionally because of forgetfulness
it does not break the fast and this
normally happens mainly in the first few
days of the month of Ramadan a person is
used to his daily activity and suddenly
Ramadan comes so unintentionally may go
to the kitchen or May pick up a bottle
of water and pour it in the glass and
have it a person goes jogging and comes
back and used to having water so it does
happen so based on the Hadith of wasam
which is mentioned in s bukari number
three in the book of fasting Hadith
number
1933 the Beloved Prophet M wasallam said
that anyone who eats or drinks
unintentionally he has to complete the
fast in the day the fast is not broken
and whatever he has eaten or drunk
Allah has provided him with that so if
you drink unintentionally the fast is
not broken but if you drink
intentionally then it is broken and
while drinking if you realize or while
eating you realize immediately you
should stop because then if you continue
it will be counted as though you're
having it with intention moment you
realize you should stop it and if
there's some food in the mouth and
realize you're fasting you should sprad
it out but un initially whatever is done
it is Forgiven what about in the case of
a person that eats it and then and maybe
15 20 minutes later suddenly realize you
know sometimes that that has happened to
me uh suddenly realize Subhan Allah I've
eaten something what an idiot I mean
what's the so then the Hadith says that
that food and drink Allah has provided
you with that so thank Allah but it
should be unintentionally done and out
of forgetfulness yes if intentionally
Allah knows your ni yes so you can fool
the people but Allah subhana tala
Dr